um welcome everyone to the
um ohsu de mice research conference
and um uh we have tried to have some
outside speakers in the pandemic
and we have um such a speaker today
uh dr tudor priya
tudor was suggested to us by guan ming
because they
collaborate but actually i know him well
he invited me a number of years ago to
visit
albuquerque and the university of new
mexico um which is a lovely place to
visit
um anyways um he is professor of
medicine pharmaceutical sciences and
chemistry and chemical biology
and also division chief for
translational informatics at the
university of new mexico school of
medicine in albuquerque
he has a both an md and ph.d
degree from the university of medicine
and pharmacy
in temisora romania he um
is a very accomplished researcher
has co-authored over 250 publications
has
10 patents and has edited two books in
his main area focus
on drug discovery and currently he's
looking at
uh development of validated artificial
intelligence models for target selection
in drug discovery
by combining numerical and text mining
in text mind information to model health
via knowledge graphs
and so he um his main uh
activity is serving as a pi of the
illuminating the druggable genome
knowledge management center which is
one of the nih common fund initiatives
so he will speak to us we'll hopefully
have some time for questions
and i always enjoy these talks that uh
um kind of cover both
bioinformatics and clinical informatics
and so we'll see some of that
so take it away tudor thank you
bill for inviting me and thank you
guangmin for inviting me i have to say
my first encounter with dr hirsch was
as a student in the mia 10 by 10 course
back in 2012
did i need to learn more about
informatics
but without further ado because i have a
lot of material to cover
essentially what we try to do is insert
informatics data science and machine
learning in
all the three pillars that i consider
three pillars of drug discovery which is
diseases
targets and drugs and through the idg
program we try to cover
all these so hopefully by the end of
today's talk
i will be able to convince you that that
is the case
so uh very briefly uh the idg
started with an interesting comment uh
from al edwards who leads the structural
genomics consortium
he essentially pointed out that wait a
minute uh
75 percent of research is done on the 10
of the genes that were known before the
human genome was mapped and this was 10
years after the
project was completed and now we're
celebrating 20 years
and you see a lot of publications
touting the successes of that recent
analysis in nature
in fact all the nature publications are
running this type of analysis
the reality is we still have a lot more
to cover
so hopefully i'll be able to convince
you of that
my adventure joining the idg started
with a seven year accumulation effort
that ended up in this publication which
is currently my most
cited paper it's uh we essentially came
up with a
mapping of all the drugs to all
targets and um in the end we covered
about 1600 fda approved drugs
and about 900 targets of which 600 plus
are
human and of course all that information
is available in pubmed central as well
so we then joined based on this
expertise we joined the
idg consortium the part that's
highlighted
in dark blue is the experimental session
section of the idg consortium we have
a stellar group of scientists that work
on g protein coupled receptors
ion channels and kinases and
they generate experimental data which
gen just
processed via help from stefan shurer
and his team in miami and then gets
deposited
into our resources which are then made
available through the knowledge
management center
and we also have uh ohsu part of this
proposal through a cutting-edge
informatics technology tool uh obviously
in
in his case it's the the reacton
group so what do we do at idg
is essentially to collect data as much
as possible from
across a wide spectrum of information
sources
uh large-scale experiments those are
given uh
preference and then we also map
things like patents and drug labels
and we're doing forays in the clinical
trial area
as well and all that information gets
standardized using
a series of anthologies including
monarch which is
spare headed by melissa hendell and her
group
and all that goes into target central
and you can access target
central through the pharos database
which is
faros.nih.gov and more information about
our consortium is that the
drugable genome net
these are some of the resources we
catalogue
of course there's a lot of them so
it would not i would not be able to do
justice to all the information
just very briefly the ones that are
marked idg are things that we
directly uh fund or support
and those that are in blue are what's
considered to be
other common fund projects and all told
we have billions of data points
but when you look at attributes
we're currently at about 700 000 on a
per
protein association basis
and we have proposed a
knowledge-based classification of
proteins so
as probably most of you are aware in
bioinformatics a lot of people spend a
lot of time
looking at the primary sequence and
identifying motifs and then 3d
structural classifications of proteins
what we try to ask address the question
is how do
how much do we know and what we know on
a per protein basis
so we came up with four categories t
clean
these are the mode of action targets
that was the subject of the nature drug
discovery paper that i mentioned
in the first place tkm these are the
uh proteins that are annotated with
small molecules
t-bio is where we know most of the
biology and of course
the dark proteins are the ones that are
understudied or
just very poorly described and so the
inner ring
shows the distribution of the four
categories and of course
wherever the function is known we have
that information as well which is the
outer
so how do we come up with the tkm
attributes we took all the approved
drugs for which we have bioactivity
please press one okay
maybe people should be on mute
was that question for me or should i
continue no
no i would continue i think that sounded
like the ohsu
voicemail system so i don't know someone
must have had their phone unmuted you
can go ahead all right
so when you look at kinases for instance
the cutoff is
uh to cover the 90 percentile of the
approved kinase inhibitors
was still is at about 30 nanomolars with
whereas if you look at ion channels
the cutoff would be at about 20
micromolar so
therefore we have this sliding scale uh
on a per target class
basis the thing that we look at
is the available publications so
with help from larceas and in denmark we
implemented something called a
fractional
publication score or paper count if you
say for example have a hundred
publications and you're interested in
the insular receptor
if all those papers only mention the
insulin receptor and nothing else then
that fractional publication count gets
to be a hundred
if uh you're actually looking at a
hundred papers that talk about twenty
thousand proteins each
uh then that is a very very small number
so we adjust for that
we also take into account the gene
reference into function
set which is maintained by ncbi we also
mine antibodypedia.com
unfortunately we don't have data on
unique antibodies we simply have to
count them
as some of you might know uh the primary
sequence of antibodies is not disclosed
for the most part so we can't really
tell
uh if they're unique or not so if you
match this criteria you're in what's
called the ignoram or t dark
otherwise you end up in bio which means
we have a decent
understanding of the biology but no
chemical matter or drugs that modulate
it
so why do we care about tdark it turns
out
that these were proteins like the leptin
receptor
or pcsk9
were truly dark proteins before uh
1995 or 2003 in in the second case
and then a critical event happened
either receptor deorfanization
or a strong protein disease association
study
and then uh a few years later typically
15 to 20
there is a drug on the market so these
are documented cases
where you progress from tdark to
clickticklin
in in less than two decades of course
the road is arduous
and it's not a linear
we can also tell you that there is a
progression so we started
first this in december 2013. so that's
the cutoff that you see there
about uh 9200 proteins were in
the dark and as you can tell over the
years
they progressed uh keeping the same
criteria
uh to about 6 400. there's not
as a dramatic improvement when it comes
to tickling
we had a slight revision in the criteria
so we had a dip there
but by the end of 2020 we were up to
uh six five nine uh the most recent
count which includes fda approved drugs
for 2020 and we just submitted a
short paper to nature drug discovery
about 15 new proteins so that number
will be
soon revised to be slightly higher
as i mentioned earlier our resources are
available through faros.nh.gov
so if you go there there are ways to
look at this
either by target or by disease or by
ligand
unfortunately we still have not yet
implemented the monarch disease ontology
we are observing the disease ontology
implemented by
lynne shrimmel at the university of
maryland at the moment
so i think that the first part of my
talk was convincing enough to point
out that we have a knowledge deficit
the number of dark proteins is steadily
decreasing
whereas the number of approved drug
targets is slowly increasing
also uh studied very well and commented
in the landmark publication of the idg
consortium
is the aspect of the grant home
we analyzed all the ro1 funded grants
the short version
is if you're going to work on a dark
protein or dark gene
the chances of getting funded are very
very small
so what we do with all this information
we try to take it into account and
focus on what's called protein disease
associations
and for that we use the resource
maintained by lars siensen
diseases and if you go to the disease
database
there are three main channels text
mining knowledge and experiments
we are making my group is making a
direct contribution
in the experimental channel through
something that we call
tiger which is target illumination by
geos analytics
and what that does is essentially a
complex
uh post processing of the geos catalog
and eliminating more accidental
reports and other focusing of those that
are
well cited and where the odds ratio is
significant so we try to clean up the
geos catalog in a
nice way the other thing that we've done
reasonably well is to implement the
bi-directional
encoder biobert and we text mine
all of the pubmed abstracts plus
the two million or so full-text papers
that are available in the subset of
pubmed central that
is thus available and this is done every
week
so if you go to diseases uh on monday
morning it's typically the latest
version is updated with the latest
information
when you look at that information and in
particular with respect to
rare diseases and rare disease day is
upon us
it's the last day of february what we
notice is
this gap in translation so if you just
count the approved orphan drugs
in europe and the in the us you notice
that
it's about the three order of magnitude
difference between those
and the publications that come out every
year and this covers three decades of
research from
1987 to 2018
so it's truly a
situation that needs to be corrected
which
is a segue to another type of research
that we've done
also with melissa peter robinson and
chris mungle
which was to re-evaluate the number of
rare diseases
and this upset plot illustrates
the overlap between nci thesaurus
disease ontology rd slim
guard which is the ncats database for
rare diseases orphanate and omim
and you can tell that complete agreement
is observed on about 300 i
presumably those are all the rare
cancers but other than that
there are resources that single-handedly
look at rare diseases
and we of course looked at leaf nodes
with respect to rare diseases
so that was all explained in the paper
so the other question that i asked was
well what if we look at these proteins
associated with rare diseases can we
understand better the rare disease
proteome and
as you probably noticed in the earlier
uh
circular histogram uh t-clean was at
three percent and tkm was at
seven percent this is roughly doubled on
a smaller subset
and on the plus side of course the dark
is much less
this has to do with the fact that as
we accumulate information about rare
diseases
it allows us to do a better annotation
of these proteins so the majority of
them
end up in in t bio and of course if i
were to do
rare disease research on a daily basis i
would start by looking at the subset
that's associated with the clean
because those would be the low thinking
fruit
and uh in relationship with that uh it's
asked by the
mouse phenotype consortium currently
comp2 but they're looking for the next
five years of funding
the question is which genes to
prioritize for the next five years
and the analysis that i started
by was to ask the question how many
of the existing impc phenotypes are
associated with rare diseases
and the answer is and what's covered in
this plot
is about 2500 genes
and this would be a really unique
opportunity where you look at the mouse
phenotypes and you ask the question
which of these phenotypes
match with the phenotypes observe in the
human disease so
it could potentially give us a wealth of
models for disease research for
each individual rare disease so again
the other obviously the title was
machine learning
this is a complex but just very briefly
we start by constructing a database as
mentioned we look at disease
associations we look at expression data
pathways uh protein protein interactions
etc and then we have scripts
initially these were done in r we have
migrated since to python
and all that gets into a database which
then
allows us to create models
so for example if you start with type 2
diabetes and if you have an existing set
of genes in
a meme that are associated with type 2
diabetes the script will generate that
for you
uh you can also have an input that's
manual input or if you're looking at
mouse phenotypes this is also
automatically extracted so
all these models are created
automatically or
by hand and then the features are
transformed according to the meta path
concept
which allows us to do what's called
graph embedding so we generate knowledge
graphs
which we then submit to xgboost and all
that allows us to
evaluate the results and one way to
evaluate the results is to look at
variable importance
at variable importance in the case of
diabetes so i looked at
this particular subset which at the time
had 51 g's this was in
september 2018
i got a model i checked all the proteins
that were predicted by this model at
least the top 300 were all
expressed in the pancreas i even tried
to look at
beta langerhans cells etc i looked at
the
hemo ferritin and him oxygenase these
are
associated with the disease called
hemochromatosis which migrates to type 2
diabetes so all in all
i thought i had a decent model i sent
this data and the predictions to mark
mccarthy
mark was at the time leading the type 2
diabetes consortium on behalf of the nih
foundation
and the accelerating medical partnership
initiative and as you probably can see
from his email
they couldn't see any enrichment from my
prediction to the genes that they were
finding through jioas or exome data
and then at the end he was like we're
questioning the training set
you probably should not have used on me
so the long story short
i got 54 genes from
mark and dan obama john who was at the
time his post-doc
i think most of this work has since been
published in nature genetics at least
the genes that they used
and in the top 24 predicted genes from
this model
they were already genes that were
strongly confirmed by geos signal
as well as imputed gold terms and
the two out of the top four variables
made sense from a type 2 diabetes
perspective so
very different model very different
story
on the plus side you can also combine
this model
with models that are associated with
type 2 diabetes through the impc
consortium
so these are five different models
where we used again these were
automatically generated by extracting
all the positive genes associated with
that particular phenotype
which is either related to glucose or
insulin level
and then looking at the top predicted
genes and then uh
trying to evaluate how many of them are
confirmed by g was
uh again this is translating from human
phenotype to from mouse phenotype to
human phenotype so
initially the prediction is done on the
mouse genes of course but then
we look at the ortholog and
these are other genes that would be in
support of the previous model that i
showed so i think
it sort of illustrates the case that you
can combine data across
species and look at different phenotypes
another way to prioritize genes for the
mouse consortium is to ask
which are the truly dark genes so this
is what we call
dark of the dark if you think of
chocolates
so currently in the data set that we
track through
pharos and our system dcrd
there's about 2500 g's that are not well
annotated in the literature
in fact most of them are the bio and the
dark
the majority of them are in the dark and
of course
even in this subset the vast majority of
them do not have a
predicted function so these are also
among those that we are considering uh
for prioritization for the
phase three of the mouse consortium
so the darching prioritization via impc
we cannot tease out causality i think
this is understood
in the machine learning community but
the trick here
is you need good data as input before
you get to good models
and we assert that the impc negatives
are true negatives
because the way uh the mouse consortium
works is
they take their mice and they phenotype
them of course
across 540 different variables
and if no significant associations or
changes are made compared to wild type
then they are not recorded so
if a gene that's been mutated lacks that
phenotype association that that's more
likely to be a true negative
so if you combine that with monogenic
rare diseases
where you understand the phenotype you
can look at mouse phenotype and compare
it directly with the human phenotype
and of course you need to exercise care
but i think it would be
a good rational strategy to prioritize
dark targets
having said that i'm going to switch to
cancer
this is an often asked question how many
cancer genes
are there and the answer is if you look
at literature
as many as two-thirds of the human
proteins
have been associated with cancer and if
you step
in with additional filters and you say i
want the publication score to be above a
certain value
and we have ways to do that with
z-scores the short version is uh
almost uh 25 of the human proteome
is significantly associated with cancer
does that mean they're good drug targets
for cancer
no i don't think so a good subset to
start with
would be what's called the cosmic cancer
gene census
and in the cosmic cancer gene census you
have a subset called the hallmarks of
cancer
and i listed here the qualities that
they have to follow from proletarian
proliferative signaling all the way to
activating
invasion metastasis and the other set
is what they call tier one genes which
includes the hallmarks
plus a subset which i maintained
separately for visualization purposes
and then a smaller set which are genes
that are more recently
identified and the evidence is not that
strong but it's strong enough to make it
into their list so all told they have a
about 700 plus genes in their system
and i try to separate them it would
perhaps not surprise you if you work in
oncology to notice
that the kinase subset which is this
dark blue
dominates in the tclean and dkm so
most of those are kinases but of course
that changes when you switch to other
words so we then use the same machine
learning model with the knowledge graph
embedding that i mentioned earlier and
metapath and asked the question can we
identify genes
that are more similar to the hallmark
of cancer or tier one or tier two and
then of course the question was
which ones to use is negatives so what
we use as negatives at least in the
first model which i think is
more strict was housekeeping genes
and this was a notion that was proposed
almost two decades ago but we also
looked at additional data from
two separate sources and confirmed that
these are housekeeping genes and also
eliminated additional criteria such as
they shouldn't have been associated with
cancer in the primary literature and we
looked
at the larcenses system
and this is just very briefly how
the models fare and
we're going to focus on this one because
it has the best uh
when you look at cross validation it has
the best confirmation so this is the
confusion matrix
and of course what you want is the
positives to be as
large as possible closer to the original
and the negatives should be as close to
the original as possible
these models sort of trail off so i'm
not paying a lot of attention to those
at the moment
the other thing that i looked at is the
feature selection and the top features
that are selected as
from the cancer cell line encyclopedia
and
the protein protein interaction nodes
from string
so how does the cancer cell and
encyclopedia look like
this is a t stochastic non-linear
embedding
plot where you take the expression data
from uh almost 1400
cell lines that are relevant to cancer
and about 16 000 genes and
what you can tell is that all the blood
cancers are nicely clustered
on one way uh male lancaster
are here in the bottom uh female breast
cancers are here
uh colon corrector are here so it does
give you some perspective that some of
these
cell lines are very well differentiated
when it comes to
things they have in common with respect
to gene expression
unfortunately not everything is as well
delineated and
i tried to put in
things that sort of overlap within the
middle
and of course that's always a problem
with the research that you still
dig into the data as much as possible
we're looking at the same plot but this
is now clustered by
a protein function
the most interesting part here is the
olfactory gpcrs which are totally
under expressed and they only cluster in
a very small subset and if you compare
that with
the non-olfactory gpcr it's a very
different story
but this is the most interesting cluster
and the other one that might be
is the epigenetic regulators i also had
hoped that nuclear receptors and
transcription factors would give me some
clue as to modulating cancers but
they do not so to be continued
but then how do we take this ccle data
and analyze it so when i look at the top
100
predicted genes with the hallmark model
i can get
16 of the tier 1 reproduced by the model
which is not a bad thing
and overall uh 76 out of the 100
through text mining already have
association with cancer so this would
probably be
good candidates for cancer research
and of course after i eliminate in the
top 30 i eliminate 11 of them which are
already in the tier 1
these are the genes and 4 of them are
kinases
and one of them is an olfactory gpcr and
i actually double checked on that one
and it looks intriguing to say the least
so to conclude this part of the talk i
think
you can use machine learning to
prioritize genes
and it says here cancer but you can
imagine if you have enough data it could
be
pretty much any disease from diabetes to
alzheimer's
but of course what we really need is
support from the
scientific community because to in order
for us to validate models that takes a
lot of effort so
the way i expressed it is that we can
generate
computer models a lot faster than the
community can
validate them and it's really work in
progress and hopefully
we'll get some people to act on this and
validate
i also wanted to put in a thought about
beyond the simple idea of targeting
proteins and nucleic acids i think
there are additional metals lipids stem
cells sugars
perhaps other entities that should be
considered
non-traditional drug targets and
we sort of think of drug target in a
boxed way we target a gene we target the
protein and those are typically what
make the cover of nature
and and science in reality
drug discovery is probably a lot more
complex
polygon nucleotides are currently making
a strong
comeback monoclonal antibodies etc plus
stem cell therapy
so a lot more work to be done
i don't know how i'm doing with time i
have
another set of slides so i could
continue or i could stop here it's it's
up to you
it's about um 1205 um
you know people typically you know leave
maybe 10 or 15 minutes for questions so
if you have something you could cover in
the next maybe
10 to 15 minutes that'd be fine uh
okay so i'm going to quickly
pass through these things and just show
you a little bit about
covet research i'm going to share the
slides so if you have questions you can
go through them and and ask
so the story with kovitz
which probably interests everyone this
is a drug repositioning
i found it very confusing and this slide
belongs to
avi mayan and his group he published
this
he collated information from a lot of
publications
and the only thing they seem to agree
upon is that remdesseviere
seems to work in seven out of the 12
papers they looked at but it doesn't
work in all of them so
the real difficulty is of course
experimental confirmation
and it goes back to the old saying that
if you
have a clock you can tell time if you
have two
you cannot tell time with precision and
that
led to this comment that we landed in
nature biotechnology
where we tried to point out to the fact
that
publications by twitter should not be
considered scientific publications
hopefully all of you know what i mean
hydroxychloroquine is not a good drug
for covid
and a lot of papers were published
strictly on computational predictions of
bioactivity which
i found uh clouds the field
uh so we must confirm that independently
which
i will show later and part of our
argument was that as a community we have
to take action
against the chloroquine story uh last is
it becomes the same story as uh
vaccines calls autism which the paper
was debunked it was retracted
andrew wakefield lost his medical
license but it was too late
it created a movement so what we did uh
back in
march at the time we thought chloroquine
was active but so we started with
chloroquine as a template
uh it has two isomers r
and s so we used both of them this is
about 3d modeling and
we identified using molecular
interaction
a set of drugs that we submitted for
experimental testing
and the compounds that we found to be
quite potent
was ammo diaquin which is an
anti-malarial drug
in our hands it was a sub nanomolar
potency
when it comes to the uh cytopathic
effect and
zuklo pentaxol which is an antipsychotic
we then uh independently submitted this
to experimental confirmation to the
university of tennessee health sciences
center so the group of colleen johnson
did work independently we bought a
separate batch of
each chemical and we sent it to her so
we had two groups that were confirming
it uh in this case with ammo diaquin
the experimental error was about two
orders of magnet but it's still active
and this has to do with different
experimental conditions
more importantly what we found is that
the active metabolite of
[ __ ] diaquin is also potent and the neat
thing about this one is that it has a
high uh concentration in
the serum the c-max and its half-life
is 500 hours which is three weeks
so our experimental results which is
where
i showed that chloroquine doesn't work
and so this is chloroquine this is an
assay called
viral title reduction so essentially you
expose the cells
to the drug and then you infect them
with increasingly higher
concentration of the virus and you look
at the protection so it's the equivalent
of a dose response but affects
those of the drug and an increasing dose
of the virus
and then you're looking at how many
orders of magnitude it protects against
the virus and the short version is that
chloroquine doesn't protect but
uh a repdesever and
this active metabolite of ammo diagram
have a similar protective effect we also
found
a protective effect from the bevel which
is a beta blocker
and zuccolo pentixol and
it's not our work i found this in bio
archive
this is experimental work in hamsters
very briefly
amodia queen protects against
infection amudia queen protects against
transmission and if your
animal is infected and another animal is
given the drug
and exposed to the infected animal the
animal that got the drug does not get
the infection
so this is pretty much confirming what
we found
but with a much bigger scale because
they had the money to do the experiments
so we think that ammo daiquin could be a
service backup for ambassador
considering that ram deserver is 25
hundred hundred dollars per cure
whereas ammo daiquin is five rupees for
10 tablets
and you only need three tablets for
three weeks and you're good to go
this would be a much better option for
the countries that cannot afford
uh or cannot access them this is there
a shout out to a machine learning uh
effort that just got accepted on monday
morning to nature machine intelligence
so
we took data from ncats and we built
a suite of machine learning models which
once you input the chemical structure
and there's three ways to do that it
standardizes it and then it predicts
uh viral activity against covid
and uh the short version is that we can
predict these bioactivities this
is the output from redial 2020
and in this case so uh ncats had not
tested decetila modiaquin
but it was predicted to be active so in
some way at least we confirm our own
findings
and we also offer on the website ways to
clearly
interpret what the models mean and how
to be used
and this paper was in peer review for
more than 180 days
so it was gruesome so
i guess drug repositioning is an
iterative exercise
and you need multiple experimental
confirmations from independent groups in
order to progress to clinical trials
so i'll stop here and look forward to
questions great um thank you
um and um uh people either um
can type questions in the box in the
chat or
they could have mute themselves um i
will um
i actually have a question for you and i
also want to
thank you for reminding me that you took
the 10 by 10 course which many
students in our list here will know
locally as bmi 510 um
and i'm glad that i contributed that uh
to your knowledge
um one one of the um you know actually i
was thinking
um as you were talking about um the um
the the the drug for for kovid that is
um um really cheap um it
um you know it it's great to identify um
drugs like that and um um of course
there's a lot more to um identifying it
in a model
in fact that that reminds me as well
that that many of the pre-print because
of this
proliferation of of model papers a lot
of the pre-print
servers have stopped um taking
models on paper but but my my question
really is
um um how often um do we
you know truly discover um better
or or even comparable new drugs by
these methods are um you know i
certainly
you know we can do a lot of computation
now we can identify genes we can
identify proteins associated with
diseases that are potential candidates
for drugs
um but um knowing what i do about
clinical research there there's a lot
more
to it than than just identifying the
drug and you know carrying it out into
phase one phase two
randomized control trials and so forth
um are there
how how often does that happen are there
good examples you could point to
um to show how this um process um
you know and the computational sides
leads to
medical advances so right now this is
a virtual topic um al edwards whom i
mentioned earlier structured economics
consortium
just uh published a commentary uh
in september last year pointing out that
we don't really get a lot out of drug
repurposing
papers all we get is a claim but
it's not followed by the clinic so
i've been spending time the little that
i have i was just looking at uh pubmed
the the subset that is the clinical
subset and then that's about 2500 papers
i looked at those that have clinical
trials
and it says that there's 140.
and then if i manually select those that
might be interesting the answer is 29
so i have to look at those 29 papers
in more detail to figure out how many
were successful but i'd say
i could probably count them on my hands
so i wouldn't say there's more than 10
that were truly repurposed
and that doesn't i'm not talking about
sildenafil which everyone knows about
and drugs like salidomide that made it
on the market so those of course are
well-known examples but those did not
come from academics or high throughput
screening or virtual screening for that
matter so
i'm specifically looking for those that
were contributed so i'd say
not a very large number for all the uh
noise that the field currently makes
there are some questions in the um chat
box actually if you um
it's usually easier to read if you go
off a screen sharing when when you go on
screen sharing it
every day so stop sharing okay uh
i just did that and in the chat box
there's some
questions so what is uh robert
dodier us what is the metric for
assessing variable importance
so i'm strictly looking at the gain
function and the cumulative gain
function
across a hundred cross-validated models
so i'm looking at the contribution
across multiple models where you do
cross-validation
i hope that answers the question and
the non-human targets that's strictly
i mean we get infections whether it's
virus parasite bacteria so anything
that's not
regret is a non-human target
so we we need to drug those two
so that's the answer to that question
are there any other questions
thank you that this is what i mean
thanks for the great talk
yeah so i have a question so in your
machine learning
approach you basically build a bigger
knowledge graph
right so from your experience is it
like always true if i have a bagel
so like basically i can collect all
these knowledge in
single graph so will knowledge
graph is a bigger that better for the
actual machine learning output
performance is for your experience
uh good question a bigger
doesn't mean better obviously you add
noise so uh what we've
started doing repeatedly is to a
perturb the model by swapping 10
of the positive labels with negative
labels and vice versa and looking at
stability of the model
and the other thing we do is we
routinely eliminate
the so-called large data sets like the
ccle
and the lynx the cellular signature
perturbation networks
so we build models with
and without links and ccle so we
essentially generate
four models one with everything one
without links one without ccle
and one without links and ccle
and then by doing this multiple
perturbations
we then ask the question how many of the
predictions
are stable in the percent of the models
and then we look at the comparison so
that's that's what we've ended up doing
lately
does that answer your question oh yeah
thank you
i i guess maybe one other um question
i can ask um um he's actually not here
but a
another member of our faculty and i've
been looking
at diagnosing rare diseases
through processing electronic health
record data
are there any i'm trying to think of how
you might
use um clinical data patient data
um it sounds like most of your work has
focused on
um literature data
are there ways that you could i'm just
trying to think um
co-occurrence of diseases um people who
patients who have had their genomes
sequenced or things like that
are there any opportunities for um
clinical data from uh patients to
complement um yes we
we do that as well so we routinely
mine uh cerner health facts
and we routinely mind truvan market scan
which used to be true when it's now ibm
so we look at those
and of course there's limitations with
each of these
data sets with cerner we still have a
problem that it's not
[Music]
following the all map data model so we
still have a problem with that
but we essentially look frequently at
comorbidities with we take loin coits
codes and and look at
uh certain uh biomarkers
like blood serum levels whatever
available and icd-10
and stuff like that
[Music]
don't have anything that's primarily
driven by myself published but
for example uh in
15. 2012-15 was in denmark at the time
so we have a paper in nature
communications where we looked at the
temporal disease trajectories
across the population of denmark so 15
years worth of
disease data and looking at the temporal
relationships
uh so that that was a it's a well-cited
paper
another question in the chat
looks like it may have gotten cut off
yeah
i assume that's the treatment
so homo daiquin is being studied as a
treatment
by folks at mount sinai and harvard but
it has not yet made the cut to the
nih adaptive trial system
i was looking at most recent
announcements there and
they are not yet looking at that as an
alternative
and i guess part of the problem is that
it was approved in the us but it's no
longer approved in the us
so it's what you call an off-market
drug and so it's the comp
the question is a bit more complex so
the best way to study this would be
to go to uh countries like india where
it's
easy to find it i should mention the
tamil daiquin
is on the who list of essential
medicines
so it is widely available it's widely
understood it's used against malaria so
it would be a simple effort to repurpose
it
well okay um um doesn't look like we
have any more questions so
um thank you for um uh giving your talk
it's very uh interesting um to hear what
you're up to
and um and maybe someday we'll get you
to portland in person
i would appreciate that thank you for
inviting me
yes thanks for coming okay okay see you
all later
okay bye bye